computers are an integral part of our
everyday lives today they are being used
in every industry around the world from
laptops to phones smart wearable devices
and many such devices
everything you can think of is being
done using a website or an application
from watching movies to ordering food or
a cam
as you might already know people write
softwares or applications to optimize
the use of these computers
with all this popularity comes a massive
demand for the people who can write or
code those applications that can run on
these computers
this has created an opportunity for
everyone to learn to program and use
that skill in almost every industry they
work in
hey everyone welcome to another yet
exciting video from simply done in this
session we will be discussing the coding
roadmap however before we begin let me
tell you guys that we have daily updates
on multiple technologies so if you're a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological friends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn so without further ado
let's get started with the agenda for
today's session
first we begin with selecting the first
programming language
after that we shall understand about the
data structures and algorithms then
later we will move ahead to online
bootcamps followed by that we will
understand the importance of working on
projects then lastly we will learn the
importance of practicing various modules
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda
so on that note let's have a small
interactive session so the first
question for you is
what are the problems you faced while
learning how to code
so please let us know what are the
hurdles that you face during your first
phase of learning how to code
this might be helpful for the beginners
and together we might be possibly find a
solution and help the beginners to learn
how to code in a better way now let's
get started with the first concept that
is selecting the first programming
language
when we start learning coding the first
thing that comes to our mind is the
language which is the perfect one to
choose and which is in the great demand
we have several programming languages at
present like python java javascript php
c-sharp and our language
let's take a look in detail about the
languages which are having a greater
career in the present time at first we
have python python is the easiest
language to learn coding python is an
interpreted general purpose programming
language that has multiple users
starting from web applications to data
analysis
this means that python can be seen in
complex websites such as youtube or
instagram in cloud computing projects
such as openstack and machine learning
etc
let us now also discuss some of the
important features of python programming
language
python is one of the free and open
source programming languages which is
ready to download and use
followed by that python has a greater
compatibility with a variety of
technologies like big data and web
applications and much more followed by
that it is also considered to be one of
the easiest programming languages to use
with limitless support that is the
community support so followed by the
first program in language let's move
ahead into the second programming
language that is java
in this modern time java is the best
language to choose nearly thousands of
applications software and development
tools are built using java
this technology is mainly used in
creating websites such as youtube google
amazon and much more
there's a lot of demand for java
developers in the software industry
because of its benefits
java also provides open source library
support which is a major benefit in the
development of applications
java also offers a wide range of
development tools which help develop
applications in a better way
now let's have a look at the few reasons
or important features of java
programming language
java is object oriented which means it
follows a programming style that
includes concepts such as class object
inheritance etc
the best thing about java apis is that
developers can use the same even if they
are not very much aware of the internal
implementation of the coding structure
next java is open source which means
there is no requirement to write code
from scratch the source is made
available for the developers
so that they can redistribute the same
and use the code as per their
requirements
java enjoys the support of extended
community that helps resolve issues as
soon as it appears
now followed by the second programming
language the third programming language
is the javascript javascript is
responsible for fast and secure
development the main advantage and
perspective are to provide more
interactivity with the users and coders
it also helps in expanding innovative
technologies which involve animation
gaming and rendering
javascript is the most popular language
which is a reason for increasing the
development speed of applications
it is easy to learn and understand which
is the major benefit for learning
javascript javascript also provides the
ability to support all browsers which
can be more beneficial to choose
javascript
now let's have a few reasons or
important features of choosing
javascript
javascript provides smooth and secure
development for the applications
javascript is also easy to pick up
javascript turns intricate details into
abstracts making things easier for the
new karma
in server server-side javascript
programming there is a large set of
libraries available in the form of note
package manager
javascript provides great user interface
for the applications
now the second interesting question for
you
so are you interested in software
development or data science are you one
of those who likes to code or are you
one of those who likes to play with data
and analyze and write machine learning
algorithms
please let us know in the comment
section below consider this to be a poll
and let us find out which number we got
the highest is it the software
development or data science
followed by javascript we have php php
is a general purpose scripting language
geared towards web development
it was created by danish canadian
programmer ramus lagrov
the php group now produces the php
reference implementation
php originally stood for personal home
page but now it time for the recursive
initialism php now let's take a look at
the important reasons or features of php
php is open source developed and updated
by developers community worldwide which
ensures that the language is not just
relevant but also in sync with the
latest technological trends
php programmed web applications and
websites are highly secure as it is an
encrypted language and easily scaled
lending to their dynamism and
flexibility php works well with linux
unix mac and windows and interfaces
perfectly with apache and mysql in a
word it covers all the bases and can be
executed like a dream on all prominent
operating systems
there are insurmountable tools handy for
developers seeking specific
functionalities and features whether
it's frameworks dependency managers
editors or documentation tools php has
good quality tools ready for use
the next one is c sharp
c sharp is a general purpose
multi-paradigm programming language c
sharp encompasses static typing strong
typing lexically scoped imperative
declarative functional generic object
oriented and component object-oriented
programming disciplines
now let's have a look at the important
features of c-sharp programming language
the development using c-sharp is easy
compared to other programming languages
if you choose c-sharp as your first
programming language you can pick up a
lot of concepts easily
one of the biggest selling points of
dotnet is that microsoft provides a wide
suite of powerful tools that can help
programmers develop better programs it
works on several different operating
systems which is another major advantage
our programming language is very
scalable and it makes it easy to build
acetic web applications this language is
mainly developed using statistics and
data science knowledge r acts as a
cross-platform because the ability to
run on any operating system
r is machine independent it supports
cross-platform operation thus it is
usable on many different operating
systems it is also an open source
programming language due to this r has a
huge community that contributes to its
environment it helps in the development
of interactive web applications and
statistics
now let's have a look at the important
features of our programming language
r is an open source programming language
anyone can work with r without any
license or fee due to this r has huge
community that contributes to its
environment
r is a machine independent programming
language it supports cross-platform
operations thus it is usable on many
different operating systems
our programming language can collect the
data from the internet through web
scraping and other means it can also
perform data cleansing
r can be useful for machine learning as
well facebook does a lot of its machine
learning research with our programming
language sentiment analysis and word
prediction is also done using our
programming language
now you might be wondering why we had to
choose only these six programming
languages right
so there is a reason for choosing only
these six programming languages that is
the stack overflow survey so according
to the stack overflow survey javascript
is the most popular programming language
with an average of 64.96
of developers followed by that we have
python with 48
after that we have java in the third
position with 38 percent of programmers
and c sharp being the fourth with 27
percent developers worldwide and
standing next to php is c sharp with
21.98 percentage of developers worldwide
and finally we have our programming
language with five percent of developers
worldwide
so these are the top six programming
languages trending according to the
statistics of stack overflow survey
now this question is for the people who
chose data science so which amongst
these two programming languages python
or r is going to be the future of data
science
so which programming language is going
to be the winner do let us know in the
comment section below now let's
understand the data structures and
algorithms concepts to help the life of
a coder
one of the best ways to develop logic
building in programming is learning data
structures concepts and these concepts
provide an idea of how to build an
algorithm
when we can build or implement an
algorithm it is easy to develop
programming skills in a person
developing an algorithm provides a good
knowledge base and also helps in
increasing the development time
now let's take a look at the importance
of online bootcamps
in these recent years online bootcamps
have shown much impact and improvement
on learning
they have provided several ways to
improve the skills in a person
we have a lot of online bootcamps in the
present era some of them which are in
huge demand are simply learn
geeks for geeks free code camp hacker
rank google academy linkedin learning
hacker earth and much more
so this question is for the people who
chose software development or coding
so let's hear it from you according to
you which programming language is going
to take over the id in the next decade
is it java or is it python or is it
javascript
do let us know in the comment section
below
now let's have a look at the importance
of working on a project
one of the best ways to improve
knowledge over coding or programming is
by working on projects it is the best
way among all the opportunities to learn
coding it involves every stage of course
and programs which is a huge advantage
to get knowledge over coding it involves
creativity and logical skills that
helped gain more knowledge on coding
working with a project also builds a
good career and makes it easy while
applying for job opportunities
most people look for real-time projects
that can be more beneficial in improving
the logic building skills in a person
these projects hold a key in upscaling
the knowledge
finally let us understand on practicing
various models of coding questions
practicing is the important key to
learning and implementing ideas when you
are ready to learn code practice as many
times as possible when we go on
practicing it improves the coding
knowledge
there are a number of online communities
available to practice and improve coding
and programming skills
they provide clear and clear examples to
understand the code and learn the code
practicing a number of models helps to
improve and solve programs in a better
way this is a huge advantage to learn
coding and programming
and this was all for today's session i
hope now you guys have got a detailed
idea of the coding roadmap if you find
the information helpful to build and
improve your knowledge of coding and
programming please subscribe to our
youtube channel if you have any
questions would you please let us know
in the comment section we have our
experts to answer it as soon as possible
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more updates from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here